vous en faites du chemin ça va toi extra
bon très bien
bien bonjour à tous vous aurez observé
que nous il est
19h1 ce qui fait que les gens qui
prennent la mauvaise habitude de ne pas
arriver à
l'heure seront désormais hipso factcto
puni euh bien euh je suis très heureux
de vous accueillir je vous rappelle que
vous êtes là dans le cadre des
Rencontres de la démocratie euh et que
euh
cette conférence
rencontre dialogue débat enfin tout ce
qu'on veut et en même temps avec
quelques minutes je crois de décalage
retransmis sur Internet et sera
disponible le compte-rendu en sera en
sera lui aussi mise à disposition de euh
chacun des lecteurs intéressés quand
Michel Cotal aura relu ce qui fait que
je la rassure elle est totalement libre
de son expression euh je suis très
heureux que Michel kotta ait accepté de
participer à cette rencontre sur un
sujet qui est à mon sens central pas
facile mais central qui est celui des
modification que la démocratie subit en
fonction euh des de l'évolution
médiatique et notamment
numérique on vient tous de vivre le la
tragique comédie de
l'UMP je sais pas si on en est sorti
mais en tout cas on vient de la vivre et
c'est évident que ça n'aurait pas pu
prendre cette dimension ni même suivre
cette dramaturgie s'il n'y avait pas eu
les médias en continu et s'il n'y avait
pas eu internet il y a une sur
réactivité j'imagine que Michel abordera
je vais pas en dire plus parce que tout
ceci touche à la question de la
fiabilité qui pour moi la confiance est
la question centrale de la démocratie on
va y revenir dans le débat Jean-Pierre
Riou et moi et quelques autres qui ont
préparé cette rencontre sommes très
heureux de votre présence et que Michel
cota est accepté de participer à cette
rencontre je vais le faire très bref
parce que tout le monde connaît Michel
cotta son son expérience et et
son sa force dans le monde du
journalisme français euh en deux mots
Michel cotas c'est quelqu'un qui vient
de
Nice son père était maère de Nice à la
Libération
euh c'est quelqu'un qui s'est engagé
très tôt dans le
journalisme après sciencep elle est
docteur en sciences politique elle est
très donc elle a été l'élève de René
Raymond qui est d'une certaine manière
notre maître à tous euh puis elle s'est
engagée dans le journalisme dans un
grand journal de l'époque qui s'appelait
il y a beaucoup de jeunes ici qui
s'appelait
combat et puis elle est passé à
L'Express sous l'aut autorité
affectueuse et stimulante de Françoise
girud et je n'ai pas oublié ce qu'elle a
dit lorsque Françoise Girou a disparu on
était très peu d'hommes politiques aux
obsèques de Françoise Girou parce qu'il
y avait un grand raout à Versailles
j'étais là philippe ségin était là
Jean-Jacques malade était là et je n'ai
pas oublié ce moment et cette rencontre
et puis elle a plus tard travaillé au
point et
puis en 1981
elle a été nommée président de Radio
France et puis quelques années encore
après elle a été nommée à la tête de la
Haute Autorité le CSA de l'époque de la
Haute Autorité de l'audiovisuel et je
parlais avec elle l'autre jour elle m'a
dit de toute façon on pouvait pas dire
non parce que on recevait un coup de fil
de miteran et
c'était
non racontera enfin bref si je dis des
bêtises tu me corriges euh c'était elle
a été une présidente de la Haute
autorité qui a résisté à bien des
pressions politiques et de cela nous lui
savons Gret après quoi tu as été à TF1
directeur de l'information à France 2
directrice générale bref tu
as quelque chose comme ça Michel cota a
occupé je parle sans notes excusez-moi
me fi en ma mémoire
Michel cotta a occupé toutes les
responsabilités euh qui dans le monde de
l'audiovisuel français en relation avec
la
politique permettent de juger des
rapports entre médias et démocratie
j'ajoute qu'elle a comme vous le savez
arbitré les grands débats de l'élection
présidentielle euh dans au moins deux
occasions si ma mémoire est fidèle et
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est
qualifié au-delà du possible pour
aborder ce sujet je veux ajouter qu'elle
est
probablement une des personnes que j'ai
rencontré qui aime profondément la
politique qui regarde avec un
regard
euh critique au sens étymologique du
terme les responsables politiques et
notamment les hommes politiques elle a
sur eux un regard absolument aiguisé
euh et euh et donc il y a il y a une
très belle histoire de sytex euh dans
Terre des Hommes je crois où
saintex atterrit quelque part dans les
Hauts Plateaux d'Amérique du Sud il
tombe sur une maison absolument
merveilleuse délabrée et il y a dans
cette maison deux jeunes fille
et il se souvient alors que dans son
enfance ses sœurs
elle distribuait des notes aux jeunes
hommes qui venaient à la table de
famille et il dit on entendait soudain
dans le silence retentir un 11 dont
personne sauf mes sœurs et moi ne
goûtaent le
charme et il a
alors il voulait laisser ajoute pour
éviter le
11 bassement pourtant et par peur du 11
je leur tendais le pain je leur passais
le sel mais je retrouvais en levant les
yeux leur douce gravité de juge que l'on
n'achète pas et bien quand je pense au
rapport entre Michel cota et les hommes
politiques je pense ainsi à cette douce
gravité de juge que l'on a pas merci de
l'accueillir merci de de cette gentille
présentation mais je je retiens je
retiens l'incitation de sytexe je trouve
ça effectivement formidable et je te
remercie de de m'en faire profiter en
quelque sorte euh voilà d'abord je suis
très contente de venir avec vous très
contente d'avoir répondu à l'invitation
de Fran soir et puis on se disait aussi
que dans un une vie précédente nous nous
sommes rencontrés avec vous à la
Bibliothèque nationale où nous avons
passé à peu près 2 ans sans nous dire
bonjour parce que on nétait pas
présenté mais on a travaillé ensemble à
la à une thèse différente et voilà
ça aur pu tourner
autrement alors je je je suis un peu
d'abord c'est un sujet que je trouve
absolument passionnant franç Bou a
raison de de le dire je trouve que ça
modifie profondément la vie politique en
tout cas c'est la
première grande modification de de
consommation de la politique d'analyse
de la politique que je vois depuis oui
que je vois
depuis voilà alors la tu peux mon aussi
non non mais ça va là j'ai rapproché le
micro bon ça va ça va pour tout le monde
alors je trouve qu'on est à un
moment qui est enfin dans toute ma vie
de journaliste c'est sûrement le vrai
tournant et un vrai tournant sur
lequel je n'ai pas d'idée préconçu et
surtout je n'ai pas de certitude absolue
et donc je trouve que c'est bien que je
vous fasse part de mes interrogations et
que d'une certaine façon vous vous me
répondiez ou que ça aide à la réflexion
je je n'ai pas de de dogm
pas plus sur sur la démocratie à la
rigueur ou je
démocratique mais sur les les les études
et les interrogations je suis pas
dogmatique et d'ailleurs le sujet que
que j'ai
été obligeamment appelé à à traiter
c'est numérique et démocratie mais j'ai
peut-être ajouté numérique média et
démocratie et c'est simple c'est parce
que les médias font pas font partie de
la démocratie alors évidemment c'est
c'est j'ai l'impression d'enfoncer des
des portes ouverte quand je dis que la
multiplication des
infos le gisement permanent
d'information sur Internet est quelque
chose pas seulement de nouveau mais dont
on sent que c'est à la fois le meilleur
et et peut-être le moins bon alors
chacun effectivement peut désormais
s'exprimer librement et
publiquement bon les blogs les clubs de
discussion les réseaux sociaux et tout
ça je suppose que vous connaissez tout
et d'ailleurs chaque parti maintenant a
son propre site et c'est tant mieux
alors de
ce de ce melstrom au fond
de
phrases petite s'il s'agit de Twitter ou
plus large s'il s'agit de de blog on
voit naître une sorte de discours
spontané qui est peu
organisé peu structuré même souvent pas
du tout et dont pourtant on ne peut pas
ne pas tenir compte les hommes
politiques ne peuvent pas en tenir
compte ne pas en tenir compte et au fond
la presse aussi alors c'est
effectivement et et c'est en cela où on
peut pas avir les choses en noir et
blanc c'est un nouvel espace de liberté
et c'est un un espace qui bouleverse les
rapports
sociaux et et qui permet de s'interroger
sur la nécessité intérieure intime qu'on
les gens sans doute de participer mais
aussi de s'exprimer par tous les moyens
comme si depuis des années ils avaient
laissé la presse s'exprimer les hommes
politiques s'exprimai et comme si d'un
seul coup ils avaient besoin s'exprimer
eux-mêmes alors toute chose étant égale
j'avais réfléchi pas mal là-dessus sur
ce qu'on appelait la téléréalité et au
fond j'avais compris et c'est au fond un
phénomène un peu de cette nature euh
pendant des années la télévision avait
les patrons de la télévision d'en haut
avait euh imposé leur programme imposé
leur format imposé leur manière de
concevoir la télévision et puis d'un
seul coup c'est comme si les gens
s'étaient dit et nous pourquoi pourquoi
on fait pas la télévision pourquoi il y
a des vedettes qui sont censé nous
représenter pourquoi on se
représenterait pas nous-même et ça a
donné la forme de télévision que je
trouve quand même la plus discutable qui
est la téléréalité donc il y a
une un réflexe de la même nature qui est
l'ensemble des des Français l'ensemble
des gens l'ensemble le monde entier en
quelque sorte dit et pourquoi moi
j'aurais pas le droit de m'exprimer moi
je suis toujours é quand je vois mes
enfants avoir des amis à l'autre bout du
monde qui ne connaissent pas et je leur
dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est que des
amis dans ces conditions bah c'est des
amis voilà c'est des amis virtuels en
quelque sorte mais si vous voulez
j'aimerais bien essayer de d'orienter
cette réflexion dans deux sens d'abord
le numérique et la presse et ensuite le
numérique et la politique alors la
conséquence sur les médias dans
elle est euh euh c'est d'abord une
explosion explosion euh des des médias à
la la multiplication des télévisions par
câble on avait déjà connu ça y compris
depuis peu les télévisions euh
d'information continue mais le numérique
terrestre et le numérique tout court y
ajoute une dimension c'est-à-dire que
maintenant enfin souvent le câble
restait euh justement dédié à ceux qui
se déclaraient
amateur d'information continue et qui
optait et qui achetait l'information
continue là le numérique terrestre fait
que tout le monde a accès à
l'information continue et que déjà ça ça
a été un premier changement par rapport
à au câble il s'agit donc d'une nouvelle
compétition au sein des médias entre des
sites internet d'information Rue 89
mdiapart pour ne pas Esser et puis les
journaux classiques les journaux écrits
classiques alors Rue 89 et Mediapart ne
peuvent exister euh que si elles sont
plus rapides
euh si elles revendiquent une nouvelle
liberté y compris celle de dire de
fausses informations ou des informations
qui se révèlent fausses par hasard mais
par la suite donc il y a une vraie de la
part de ces nouveaux médias écrits une
stratégie forcément des scoopes au fond
euh qu'est-ce qu'on veut si on regarde
mdiap on cherche effectivement si kusac
a ou non un un compte en Suisse ou s'il
l'a eu ou s'il l'a eu il y a 20 ans ou
s'il l'aura dans 20 ans donc c'est une
stratégie des scoup qui est euh
obligatoire et puis une stratégie des
des documents arrachés en quelque sorte
euh des documents arrachés aux avocats
arraché aux juges euh arraché aux hommes
politiques euh dans cette il y a
toujours évidemment ce cette volonté de
temps en temps d'avoir des documents euh
secrets ou réservés je me rappelle un
journaliste du Monde qui avait comme
principe de ce qu'il arrivait dans un
bureau de ministrees de poser ses notes
sur les notes du ministre et puis après
de repartir avec les documents je ne
dirai pas son nom mais c'est un
journaliste du Monde euh donc ça a
toujours un peu existé mais au moins
quand le journaliste du Monde faisait ça
après il se donnent le temps de euh de
voir ce qui publiait ce qui publiait pas
ce qui était utile à publier ce qui
était un scoop ce qui était pas un scoop
voilà alors là main maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que du côté des
des journaux euh par Internet euh cette
compétition est est absolu et à cela
s'ajoute
euh la compétitivité donc entre ces euh
nouveaux médias et les innombrables
blogs réflexion qui émanent de tout le
monde c'est vous voyez c'est comme s'il
y avait trois niveaux il y a le niveau
de la place classique écrite ou
télévisée et puis au-dessus il y a le
niveau des journaux par
Internet qui se permettent plus de
rapidité qui ont plus de rapidité et
encore plus rapide tout ce qui est
échange des réseaux sociaux échange par
tweet échange
par par SMS et c'est donc une
information qui est maintenant délivrée
à tout alure sans jamais le recul de la
réfle s souvent le recul de la
réflectionion et moi j'étais très étonné
pendant la dernière campagne électorale
présidentielle j'étais moimême sur une
antenne à côté d'un député qui
commentait et je voyais pendant il était
sur je voyais sa tablette et sur la
tablette il y avait les commentaires
immédiats de Jean-Michel apathti de tous
les journaliste qui minute après minute
commentait l'information c'est sans
alors
c'est formidable parce que quand même le
le métier de journaliste c'est d'avoir
un recul et d'intégrer un certain nombre
de d'informations et puis de les
restituer
aussi aussi largement et aussi
franchement qu'on le peut mais quand on
voit même des journalistes aguéris c'est
pas une critique hein c'est c'est quand
on voit même des journalistes
aguéris se privé de ce recul et au
contraire accentuer l'instantanéité de
leur réaction c'est quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup surpris et pendant ce temps-là
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des blogueurs en
direct continuer à discuter à analyser
pendant sur la tablette de mon
voisin l'instantanéité et ça ça m'
beaucoup ça m'avait beaucoup enfin pas
choqué interroger parce que c'est donc
une information délivrée à à toute
allure et qu'est-ce qu'une information
délivrée à tout à l'URE c'est une
information qui par nature fait une
grande place à l'émotion laisse
l'émotion dominer la réflexion
ça je je c'est je me demande souvent si
c'est un des un des aspects les plus
important c'est-à-dire que tout se juge
maintenant sur une émotion un réflexe
une sensibilité et jamais en replaçant
enfin
jamais en tout
cas en tout cas en ce qui concerne un
certain nombre de blogueurs jamais
replacé dans un contexte alors mais plus
généralement pour reprendre le mot de de
pierreasky de qui dirige un des
dirigeants de Rue 89 c'est vrai que la
place du lecteur a changé il est dans la
boucle de l'information c'est ce que dit
piaski et c'est vrai la place du lecteur
des plus extérieurs est dans la boucle
de l'information c'est-à-dire qu'il
participe au débat et qu'il participe en
temps réel alors j'ai pris par exemple
exemple tout à l'heure j'ai regardais
j'ai voulu regarder une interview de
Dominique volton aux écho que j'avais
beaucoup aimé Dominique volton est un
sociologue expert des médias qui
réfléchit beaucoup et en tout
cas don c'est le métier et alors il a
fait un papier vraiment
formidable dans c'est les échos ou la
tribune euh bon peu importe he c'est éc
je ne vois pas en tout cas l'article
fait trois feuillets et quand j'ai
appuyé pour avoir la article pour le le
pouvoir il y a
derrière 36 feuillets et d'ailleurs ça
n'est pas fini de réaction des gens et
de commentaires c'està-dire de gens
absolument
inconnus qui sont très intéressés par ça
qui disent des choses intéressante mais
ça veut dire que maintenant vous n'avez
plus un papier un article qui n'entraîne
pas une flopppée de commentaires qui
vont dans un sens qu'on ignore
généralement mais en attendant très
ouvert c'est que la j' très quand on
voit les volumes maintenant des des des
commentaires on s'aperçoit que les
commentaires sont presque plus
important que l'article alors la culture
du numérique permet donc et c'est pas
forcément mauvais mais permet au lecteur
d'aller au-delà de son statut et d'être
partie prenante du débat sur l'actualité
alors quand je dis ça quand je dis que
c'est pas forcément mauvais c'est bien
même que les gens se sentent concernés
c'est bien qu'ils pensent que lorsqu'ils
lisent quelque chose ils ont droit à la
réaction et qu'il on bon mais évidemment
c'est une attitude qui bouleverse de
fond en
comble le phénomène de la presse tel que
nous l'avons connu au fond le
journaliste très longtemps a été comme
le juge d'ailleurs absolument sans
sanction on pouvait écrire ce qu'on veut
de temps en temps si on porte atteinte à
à une image d'un homme politique ou à la
défense nationale oui on peut être la
loi peut vous mettre en question mais au
fond les journalistes sont jamais remis
en cause par personne et ils vivent
comme ça depuis des
années même les hommes politiques sont
finalement on imagine d'ailleurs ce que
les hommes politique pensent l ce qui
répondent à certaines questions des
journalistes du genre et toi alors et
combien tu gagnes bon on imagine mais
enfin ça ne se fait pas et là ça se fait
donc de toute façon ça bouleverse le la
presse et la place du journalisme elle
reste sans doute fondamentale mais elle
est bien en cause dans tout ça elle
reste fondamentale euh parce que il lui
revient de de de hiérarchiser de
hiérarchiser l'actualité et
d'hérarchiser ce qui est important et ce
qui ne l''est pas mais son rôle est
contesté par l'ensemble des utilisateurs
du numérique euh qui juge avoir autant
de compétences et parfois c'est vrai
autant de compétences euh et donc
peut-être plus pour établir cette
hiérarchie enfin je je crois que
Dominique volton a raison de mettre le
doigt sur ce qui est tout de même plus
inquiétant je vous le cite parce que je
trouve que c'est ce qu'il avait de plus
synthétique sur le problème la folie de
la vitesse qui a gagné le fonctionnement
des médias ne peut pas à ce point
déstabiliser la politique Nicolas
Sarkozi voulait en quelque sorte une
politique à la vitesse des médias c'est
impossible et dangereux d'autant que
cette obsession de la vitesse de
l'hypermédiatisation est moins un idéal
que le résultat d'une concurrence
farouche qui ne dit pas son nom entre
les médias classiques et les nouveaux
supports internet réseaux sociaux
Twitter cette course contre la montre
n'est pas n'a pas grand-chose à voir
avec l'idéal de l'information au moins
au nom de la enfin au nom de laquelle
elle est faite et c'est vraiment euh je
je retrouve absolument ce que ce que ce
que je pense dans cette dans cette euh
page avec à la fois les les mirages et
l'attirance on a toujours voulu faire
des scoops nous les journalistes mais
pas à n'importe quel prix euh et ben je
comprends l'attirance pour les SCOOP je
me pose la question d'une tirance pour
cette
vitesse imaginable donc là encore le
meilleur et le pire le meilleur je l'ai
dit l'implication du lecteur dans sa
lecture le pire c'est la non
hiérarchisation de l'information
l'amplification des émotions
le non respect des compétences et
surtout le refus de
l'expertise derrière le moi je moi je
suis aussi expert que les autres alors
quel rapport avec la
démocratie dans la mesure où le
pluralisme de la presse on reviendra
après sur les rapport avec la politique
mais sur la presse quel rapport avec la
démocratie de la presse dans la mesure
où le pluralisme de la presse est un
élément essentiel de la démocratie où il
est garant de la démocratie on pourrait
dire que la démocratie y gagne puisque
le plural et par définition plus grand
depuis la naissance d'Internet mais
revers de la médaille si personne
n'écoute les arguments de l'autre si
chacun s'engage d'une manière parallèle
dans sa démonstration sans si chacun
croit que sa vérité est plus importante
que celle de l'autre si lesé lecteur
pense que la presse ne reflecte qu'une
opinion minoritaire ou que l'opinion des
patrons ou que l'opinion des grands
patrons comme le dis certains ou que
l'opinion des syndicats comme le disent
d'autres alors si penseent que la presse
est minoritaire ça veut dire que son
influence est remise en question et que
sa son pluralisme ne sert finalement
plus à grand-chose quant à la presse
donc elle risque finalement la contagion
d'un système où la liberté est sans
limite liberté au nom de quoi la pipe la
pipolisation le parler de soi l'impudeur
presque dans le narcissisme
l'autocongratulation ou au contraire la
flagélation systématique des autres
devient un idéal alors bon je pense que
j'ai assez parlé de la presse mais
deuxième volet peut-être de la réflexion
qu'on peut avoir c'est je sais pas si je
suis trop longue ou
trop deuxème volet de la réflex qu'on
peut
avoir surtout au lieu où nous sommes
hein c'està-dire au siège d'un parti
politique alors là encore on retrouve le
meilleur et le pire alors le meilleur le
gisement d'information sur internet et
il a donc la possibilité de s'exprimer
livement et publiquement
euh cela donne à coup sûr un nouvel
espace à l'espace
démocratique mais le problème est que
l'expression de cette souveraineté
populaire en quelque sorte met en cause
plus exactement dépasse les cadres de la
de la démocratie qui a longtemps été la
NRE et qui est toujours la d'utre qui
s'appelle la démocratie représentative
alors de quoi serait-elle représentative
à partir du moment où chacun la met en
cause elle est à la base de notre
démocratie cette démocratie
représentative et c'est elle aujourd'hui
qui est menacée depuis les débuts de la
politique dans les démocraties les plus
avancé les choses publiques les
décisions politiques sont partagées
entre l'État c'est-à-dire l'exécutif et
le législatif euh plus largement les
lieux de décision les experts
et les syndicats grosso modo et
l'irruption des blogs des médias
numériques crée une sorte de génération
spontanée de nouveaux acteurs de de la
vie
politique qui çaa pose évidemment le
problème des fameux corps intermédiaires
on voit bien le problème alors celui des
corps intermédiaires pas de différence
entre les corps intermédiaires et
l'ensemble des Français autant de savoir
autant le partage de l'information et au
fond on pourrait dire que par rapport au
corps intermédiaire né ce qu'on peut
appeler les corps élémentaires chacun de
nous est un corps élémentaire par
rapport au corps intermédiaire je trouve
ça de nature à à changé beaucoup les les
relation qu'on peut avoir avec ces
fameux corps intermédiaires d'ailleurs
difficile à définir et où qu'il soit
alors ça change également l'ensemble des
rapports sociaux et politiques parce que
il n'est plus important pour ceux qui
ont ce ce cette technique et ce savoir
il est plus important de déléguer aux
responsabilités politiques les facultés
d'élaborer les politiques puisque
franchement dans des club de réflexion
qui ne passe pas par la case des partis
politiques dans des on qui ne passe pas
par la case du
gouvernement on se retrouve habilité et
incité à faire un certain nombre de
propositions c'est-à-dire que les partis
politiques n'ont plus le monopole des
propositions les conséquences sur la vie
des partis il me semble sont évidentes
la démocratie représentative telle
qu'elle fonctionne sera vite
insuffisante je ne dis pas qu'elle
doivent l'être mais elle le sera
vite comment organiser une ce relais
entre la consultation permanente
l'intervention immédiate et la
désignation d'élus après des cons ation
élective traditionnelle alors certains
dans dans ceux qui étudient certains des
sociologues de de ces médias invente
même qu'on puisse avoir un parlement
virtuel et il fixe des espèces de de de
condition à à ce Parlement virtuel qui
n'aurait pas le droit de critique mais
qui aurait simplement le monopole des
propositions si tenter que 200 personnes
se retrouvent sur un une proposition
commune mais vous voyez à quel point ça
menace l'existence même des partis
politiques et enfin le pouvoir politique
est sans
sanction permanente et sous sanction
permanente pardon la pression
immédiate de cette communauté de
blogueurs
invétérés
s'applique tous les jours à tous les
instants sur les partis politique et
au-delà sur les hommes politiques sur
leurs idées et euh on peut se même se
poser la question est-ce que
c'est le comble de la démocratie ou
est-ce que c'est le contraire de la
démocratie et ça franchement c'est la
question sur lequelle je suis assez
incapable d'avoir une
idée construite complètement par
certains côtés je trouve que plus
nombreux sont les gens qui s'intéressent
à la politique et mieux sa et par
certains d'autres côtés je me dis que à
un moment donné une démocratie
a son son rôle est quand même de de
diriger un pays et à partir de moment
elle est sous un feu constant de
critique contradictoire mais qui n'ont
pas pour but d'organiser le pouvoir
politique mais au contraire de le
désorganiser je me pose vraiment des
questions sur quel est le type de
pouvoir politique qui résiste à tout ça
et on voit bien que l'accélération de la
vie politique
démontre que lorsque la vie politique
est très rapide et moi je comprends
assez bien le désir qu'avait Nicolas
Sarkozi d'aller vite d'occuper le
terrain en se disant si je ne l'occupe
pas alors qui l'occupera mais en
revanche on voit bien que la tentation
inverse du président actuel pour pas
rentrer dans la politique qui est je
peux pas m'exprimer sur tout je peux pas
je vais pas dire les caps parce que
d'abord les caps changent et et il faut
pas que je parle tout le temps
sinon je je je vais me contredire il
vaut mieux se répéter que ce contredire
certes maison et on voit bien comment
cette volonté de ralentir l'action
politique est en fait quelque chose qui
accélère la réaction à ce qu'on appelle
une inactivité donc je trouve que on est
vraiment dans dans le nœud du problème
et pour vous dire ma ma conviction je ne
sais pas comment une démocratie résiste
au tir à boulet rouge de tout le monde
tout le temps voilà c'est sur cette
interrogation assez pessimiste je dois
dire que je
m'arrête
alors Jean-Pierre rillou va dire un mot
dès l'instant que j'aurais branché nos
affaires
là non j'ai
dû il paraît qu'il faut que ça
chauffe voilà bien oui ça ça marche non
deux mots
vraiment sur le fond de la
question il faut voir que que tout ce
que les médias nous entraînent dans ce
cycle cette instantanéité dans cette
désormais cette je dirais cette prise en
charge par l'individu parce que c'est ça
qu'il y a au fond il y a une espèce de
vous avez dit le corps élémentaire dans
dans tout ça il faut dire que ça
participe et c'est pour ma part c'est
quelque chose qui qui qui m'obsède
depuis bien longtemps et au titre de de
mon métier
d'historien nous vivons aujour
aujourd'hui dans des sociétés qui sont
en crise profonde de la
temporalité à tous les étages si je puis
dire pas seulement au niveau de
l'information
ou voyez ce que sont les décalages
actuels entre je dirais les temps
sociaux et les temps de vie et les temps
de et les temps les âges de la vie et
les temps personnels de de la vie
quotidienne espèce de fébrilité
constante parce que le le temps nous
échappe toujours bon pour raisons
alors dans des sociétés qui ont rompu le
fil du temps ou qui sont en train de
rompre le fil du temps c'estàd une
scansion passé présent avenir et qui
donc nous nous les historiens nous nous
analysons
ça soit élégamment en disant oui c'est
des sociétés qui sont en train de
chercher un nouveau régime d'historicité
tu parles mais c'est des sociétés qui
effectivement sont en proie à ce que
alors là on sait appeler le le
présentisme finalement cette espèce des
de présent éternel multiforme répétitif
et instantané constamment et et les
médias ne font que ne font que que
qu'accélérer les choses alors c'est
c'est l'idée que au fond le temps n'est
plus à la verticale si je puis dire dans
dans dans ce que nous disait Michel cota
il y a toujours ça l'idée que c'est un
temps qui n'a plus dans lequel on a plus
confiance finalement c'est un temps sans
autorité ni compét finalement et du coup
on est dans un un temps à l'horizontal
n'est-ce pas à l'horizont
maîtrisé et très mal maîtrisé par les
seuls je dirais les seuls corps
élémentaires bon alors bon ça c'est une
première remarque donc le problème est
plus grave que que que à la limite que
la démocratie c'est c'est c'est c'est
nos vie de tous les jours et celle de
nos enfants dans tout cela alors en
terme je dirais démocratique
oui alors ça c'est une conséquence
gravisse que Michel cotta très bien dit
c'est que nous sommes en train de nous
éloigner et et on habille ça comme comme
l'on veut on peut appeler ça démocratie
de proximité on peut appeler
ça à proximité de l'individu et et du
lieu où il VI ou
participative on est en train sans doute
de de de perdre probablement je ce qui
est un un des ressort de fond de la
démocratie depuis qu'il y a des agoras
finalement la démocratie quel que soit
le qualificatif qu'on y ajoute elle est
toujours délibérative et est
délibérative c'est des gens qui
s'assemblent pour délibérer de quelque
chose et pour qu'il y ait une
délibération et le mot est exceptionnel
extraordinaire n'est-ce pas quand on
vient d'entendre Michel cota pour une
délibération il faut qu'il y ait un
ordre du jour ordre du jour voilà et il
faut qu'il y ait relative instruction
n'est-ce pas du propos il faut qu'il y
ait auparavant auparavant auparavant
voilà qu'il y ait une oui une
instruction un dossier une préparation
enfin que c'est donc c'est à la fois
dans ce contexte du je dirais de la
temporalité rompu ou en voie d'être
rompu et dans celui de la la crise
profonde de la démocratie de
délibération qui dépasse démocratie
représentative de proximité ou
participative dans tout c'est comment on
on on on instruit et alors donc ça nous
entraîne à à poser à Michel cotta 1000
autes question que vous allez faire
mieux que moi euh et du coup ça ruine et
vous n'avez pas souvent prononcé le mot
Michel c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'information dans une démocratie
maintenant voilà qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'information he dès lors que onaccepte
que l'horizontal et qu'on ne tolère plus
le vertical est dicté voilà merci
Jean-Pierre alors je vous
propose je vous
propose que nous ayons devant nous 35
minut
de dialogue la règle vous savez ici
c'est 30 minutes intervention Michel a
été impeccable et 30 minutes de dialogue
on va l'étendre un peu parce que c'est
c'est bien que nous ayons apporté et
c'est un sujet qui est assez profond et
délicat à analyser donc maintenant si
vous voulez
bien je vous propose qu'on donne la
parole à la salle pour pour trois
questions mettons et puis Michel
répondra et puis vous en aurez à nouveau
trois puis Michel
répondra et on verra à peu près où on se
trouve dans le temps je dirai un petit
mot à la fin et ainsi nous aurons
respecté le contrat l'engagement qui est
lui aussi à la base de la démocratie
vous avez la parole alors tout le monde
a a le je vais essayer comme c'est notre
habitude d'alterner les voix féminine et
masculine et on commencera par féminine
oui bonjour j'étais journaliste d'agence
à l'agence reire pendant presque 10 ans
et euh et nous avions comme déontologie
à l'agence reutire de aussi grave et
important qu'il soit un scoop ne pouvait
pas être envoyé sur le fil si on avait
pas euh une ou deux confirmations et je
me souviens d'un d'un d'un épisode où il
y a toutes les agences de presse à
l'époque où il y avait des agences
plusieurs agences de presse car
maintenant il y en a plus que deux
euh a donné la mort de d'un dirigeant
soviétique je sais plus c'était le
ministre de la Défense ou quelque chose
comme ça et et de Moscou on nous
téléphoné en disant mais qu'est-ce que
vous faites pourquoi vous ne donnez pas
le l'inform
nous n'avions pas la confirmation et
pourtant on se battait à la minute près
avec UPI avec AFP et cetera donc cette
urgence dans l'information existe à
existé et existe probablement toujours
mais ce qui a changé j'ai l'impression
c'est la
déontologie puisque chez mediaap part ou
les autres médias don vous avez parlé il
y a derrière des journalistes et si leur
déontologie leur interdisait de mettre
sur le fil ou sur le site des
informations dont ils ont juste entendu
parler par hasard euh ça ne donnerait
pas la même impression de d'un d'un
espèce de course à au scoop à l'échalote
j'allais dire euh qui désoriente
complètement les le public donc est-ce
que c'est vraiment l'Internet le média
qui est à la à la base et la cause de
tout cela ou est-ce que c'est tout
simplement un changement de mentalité et
un oubli de déontologie et un
renoncement de la déontologie qui est
beaucoup plus grave à mon avis merci
beaucoup
masculin tu essaes de varier dans la
salle merci alors en fait moi serait
question en deux points tout à l'heure
on a parlé justement des de la relation
entre les hommes politiques et les
journalistes est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que le fait de bien souvent
lorsqu'on découvre une information
capitale sur un homme politique entendre
des journalistes sur les plateaux télé
répéter que c'est un secret de
polychinel et que vous êtes au courant
de ces informations depuis bien
longtemps et que vous ne l'avez pas
spécialement partagé avec le public n'a
pas créé justement une impression de de
voilà de complicité entre les hommes
politiques et les journalistes et
concernant le mot que vous avez utilisé
tout à l'heure pour l'affectif on a à
mon sens bien souvent l'impression qu'on
est gouverné par
l'affectif bien souvent les lois sont
passées suite à un événement précis même
lorsque ça n'a plus de sens et on est
capable de passer pour un exemple bête
on est capable de passer une loi sur les
Molos en ayant l'impression qu'un
pitboule a attaqué un enfant même
lorsque c'est un espagol ça simplement
parce que on est dans la réaction
immédiate enfin les Espagnoles c'est
rare c'est malheureusement arrivé c'est
malheureusement arrivé mais voilà on a
l'impression d'être gouverné par
l'affectif et on a l'impression qu'il y
a une conivance entre la classe
politique et les journalistes merci
beaucoup féminin féminine la
voix par rapport en fait au journalistes
aujourd'hui qui sont de plus en plus
étiquetés de gauche ou de droite et qui
se revendiquent d'ailleurs de cette
étiquette notamment on pense à
l'émission sur BFM TV direct de gauche
direct de droite et à tel point aussi
que certains notamment dans la droite
forte que je ne partage pas évidemment
au passage revendique qu'il y ait des
quotas de journalistes de droite et de
gauche des quotas voilà entre guillemets
hein voilà là
encore et c'était pour savoir est-ce que
vous pensez en fait que c'est une
évolution positive dans le sens d'une
plus grande transparence vis-à-vis de
l'opinion politique ou alors est-ce que
au contraire c'est plutôt en fait une un
travers de l'évolution actuelle des
médias h tu veux répondre aux trois ou
tu en veux trois de plus avant de
répondre tu répond parce que c'est déjà
c'est déjà euh euh compliqué alors euh
c'est vrai que pant très longtemps pour
répondre à à vous madame qui était
correspondante donc d'une agence de
presse c'est vrai que pendant très
longtemps les journalistes seuls avaient
accès aux dépêches ça s'appelait des
dépêches à l'époque
euh il y avait un jeune stagiaire
généralement qui nous amenait des bouts
de papier euh à tout alure et bon mais
personne n'avait euh accès à ça personne
d'autre que les journalistes mais ce qui
a effectivement changé c'est que
maintenant euh n'importe quelle nouvelle
passe immédiatement je me demande
d'ailleurs comment j'ai fait l' il a 2
ans avec Colombani on a fait un rapport
sur la FP dont on concluait qu'on ne
savait pas comment ça pouvait durer
longtemps étant donné que les dépêches
n'existe plus qu'elles sont partout
avant même d'être connu des journalismes
enfin bon c'est un autre sujet alors
bien sûr il y avait une déontologie il y
a une déontologie qui reste celle de la
FP aujourd'hui qui est ne
pas ne pas larguer une nouvelle sur les
fils avant qu'elle a été mais justement
avant qu'elle été confirmée mais
justement euh les médias Internet ne
peuvent exister que s'ils vont plus vite
sinon ils sont sur le même c'est c'est
ça le fond de la course c'est que ils ne
veulent pas en rester justement à la
vérification parce que ça ça ralentit si
vous voulez être avant les agences de
presse il faut publier quelque chose
sans le prans sans le vérifier alors
c'est
c'est c'est c'est consubstantiel au
phénomène de internet ça ce que ce que
vous dites c'est pas un changement de de
déontologie c'est parce que les
déontologies de la FP a pas changé la
déontologie du monde en gros a pas
changé c'est la technique même qui est
devenue en quelque sorte le fondateur de
cette dynamique et de cette vitesse
nécessaire c'est pour ça que je trouve
que c'est beaucoup plus grave que la
déontologie la deuxème question sur le
rapport entre les hommes politiques et
les journalistes alors ça vous
poser une question je veux dire si vous
êtes pas le premier à me la poser
alors moi je je connais bien François
beou il m'arrive d'avoir une conivance
avec lui mais la conivance ne ne
m'empêche pas du tout d'écrire ce que je
pense j'ai j'ai vu des tas de gens dans
ma vie qui me disaient qui me disaient
des choses c'est pas parce que quand
vous allez quand vous êtes journaliste
sportif vous allez interviewer
NLK où bon on vous taxe pas de
connivance parce que bien sûr vous allez
prendre vos informations à la source
c'est le contraire qui sera embêt c'est
justement de les prendre sur le fil
d'Internet donc il y a pas de connivance
il y a que pour les hommes politiques ou
pour les femme politique on pose ce
genre de question oui on va à la source
quand il y a quelque chose il m'est
arrivé d'appeler François beou en disant
pendant l'élection et alors qu'est-ce
que vous faites euh est-ce que vous êtes
vous nêtes pas allé trop loin j'ai peur
pour vous je me rappelle je mêmeon et et
c'est normal mais est-ce que c'est je
pense que c'est pas une connaance à
partir du moment o on reste libre et
c'est la moindre des choses de son
écriture alors ce que vous me posez sur
la est aussi un peu plus compliqué pour
un journaliste et il m'est arrivé
évidemment d'avoir des confidences euh
très peu hein je vous fais bon très peu
et de me dire si je les balance comme ça
j'en AAI plus jamais donc vous prenez un
peu plus de temps en vous disant et
c'est la moindre des choses en vous
disant euh moi je cite toujours
euh l'expérience que j'ai eu qui éit un
scoop sur le le départ de Jacques Chirac
en 1976 où en juillet Marie-France Garou
me dit il s'en va c'est pas la peine il
s'en va il a envoyer sa lre de démission
voilà ça lettre de démission euh mais il
ne il attend que giscar dise oui ou non
bon je suis rentré au
journal j'ai la chance d'avoir des des
patrons qui faisaient leur boulot et
donc j'ai dit à François Girou voilà
j'ai j'ai vu la lettre Chirak s'en va et
on était le 26 juillet
et réfléchis longuement et je dis je dis
quand même à Françoise mais est-ce que
je peux avoir été l'objet d'une
manipulation de mariefance garot qui
était quand même connu pour
ça donc nous avons attendu nous n'avons
rien dit à tel point que pendant un mois
je me suis dit je me suis trompé j'ai
j'ai été eu cette lettre de démission
était une fausse lettre de démission et
je suis parti en vacances mais la mort
dans l'âme en me disant là j'ai je me
suis fait avoir comme un bleu
heureusement qu'on a pas passé
heureusement qu'on a pas passé cette
nouvelle et puis la nouvelle est tombée
hein bon alors c'est pour ça que c'est
souvent il faut de temps en temps si on
veut garder sa sour source ne pas la
trahir tout de suite alors ça peut être
une ça peut passer passer pour une
euh pour quelque chose de de trop euh
proche ou quelque chose de trop mais
mais je crois que c'est nécessaire c'est
juste le recul qu'il faut et dont je
parlais tout à l'heure pour euh
euh réfléchir sur la nouvelle telle
qu'elle vous a été donnée alors
peut-être que là j'ai trop attendu
j'aurais sans doute mieux fait de
publier tout de suite je sais pas du
tout ce que ça aurait donné d'ailleurs
mais euh vous voyez j'aurais pu aussi me
ridiculiser bon euh donc et gouverné par
les motifs vous avez par l'affectif vous
avez tout à fait raison je trouve que
les hommes politiques eux-mêmes sans
doute parce qu'il précède ou parce qu'il
croi précéder la réaction justement des
innombrables blogueurs et par et
nouveaux acteurs de la vie publique qui
vont plus vite mais plus vite que euh
plus vite qu'ils ne devrait aller c'est
vrai que la on peut
pas absolument réagir sur les pitbll le
lendemain et puis après réagir sur les
gitans sur lendemain on est d'accord
mais bon mais ça c'est de la faute des
hommes politiques mais la question qu'on
se posait la question que je posais à la
fin est-ce qu'elles peuvent est-ce
qu'ils peuvent maintenant réagir
autrement à partir du moment où vous
avez des tas de
réseaux mobilisés ou vous avez vu enfin
la valanche de de de de dépêche et de
d'intervention sur le crime sur les
l'horrible chose américaine et
l'horrible mort des 20 des 20 gosses bon
est-ce qu'on peut réagir autrement oui
il faut voilà il faut mais ça va pas ça
va être de moins moins commode voilà
ensuite les journalistes
étiquetés alors ça dépend la réponse
elle
est elle est différente parce que une
presse d'opinion ça existe et ça doit
exister donc ça ne me gêne absolument
pas que des journalistes dans une presse
d'opinion soit étiqueté mais ce qui me
paraît en revanche relativement
dangereux et je l'prouve ça ça me
concerne
aussi la multiplication des tribunes
entre
journalistes fait que vous êtes obligé
de vous démarquer vous pouvez pas dire
la même chose bon et et ça influe sur la
nuance que vous pouvez si vous
travaillez dans la nuance alors vous
êtes incompréhensible donc si quelqu'un
vous dit moi ça m'arrive tous les
samedis à Europe
si quelqu'un dit ah quand même Sarkozi
c'est un grand bonhomme et CEA je suis
obligé de dire ah pas tellement que ça
bon et voilà et donc c'est vrai que
c'est un problème que la espèce
d'exposition il me semble excessive des
des journalistes tous les jours tout ça
implique évidemment une prise de
position souvent sans nuance alors il
faut résister il faut
essayer d'apprécier certaines choses et
de contrer certaines choses sans sans
que votre sentimentalité ou que votre
affectif soit difficilement soit
concerné mais c'est vrai que ça pose un
problème sauf pour les journalistes moi
ça me gêne pas que le type de de
l'humanité dise ce qu'il pense euh du
gouvernement actuel en revanche euh
quand je vois j'ai toujours une gêne
quand les gens de Figaro s'empoigne avec
les gens du Nouvel Observateur
voilà
ça n'est pas seulement une question qui
touche aux médias à la
démocratie c'est une question qui touche
plus profondément
à la
civilisation que nous avons
formé parce que c'est une question qui
touche à la question de la
laïcité moi je me je je me bats depuis
des années tout le monde sait ici quel
est mon
engagement sur ce sujet de
Fond pourtant étant croyant et ne
rougissant pas ou ne me dissimulant pas
de te
l'être parce que tout ça revient à
l'idée ces gens qui disent il faut qu'on
sache où ils sont et il faut qu'on
équilibre tout ça revient à l'idée
que quelqu'un qui a
un certain nombre de valeurs des
engagements personnels il va toujours
juger dans le sens de son
étiquette comme si on
exigeait pour qu'il enseigne les
lumières d'un professeur de philosophie
ou de lettres ou d'histoire qu'il soit
lui-même
agnostiqueé contestataire de
l'église qu'il sousccrive
lui-même à la au message au jugement
qu'il porte or ce que nous croyons et ce
que nous croyons dans cette maison
précisément c'est que on est libre y
compris à l'égard de son propre
engagement c'est une chose
extraordinairement profonde parce que
c'est de la liberté humaine qu'il
s'agit c'est de l'émancipation à l'égard
y compris de soi-même moi je
prétends j'ai enseigné 10 ans je
prétends que croyant j'ai enseigné
Voltaire je crois aussi bien en tout cas
qu'il pouvait être enseigné et j'ai
expliqué euh à mes élèves à mes
étudiants ce que voulais dire écre inf
écrasons l'infâme l'infâme étant
l'église et j'aiexliquaé
pourquoi un homme de cette intelligence
vivacité
d'esprit élevé dans le giron de l'Église
pouvait éprouver ça à cette époque moi
je crois que c'est une grande
revendication de de d'humaniste
que de prétendre qu'on n'est pas
prisonnier y compris de ses propres
opinions et que donc il faut refuser ça
en
revanche si vous voulez qu'on poursuive
d'un pas encore c'est une extraordinaire
dégradation de voir il y a des émissions
et des chaînes qui ont été citées qu'il
y a un mouvement
revendiquer de résumer le débat à deux
positions caricaturales euh euh vue de
droite ou direct de droite ou direct de
gauche parce que ça c'est au fond la
même le le la même perversion euh euh je
demande même pas qui est direct du
centre ou coup de boule du
centre je demande qu'on défende
le la liberté de l'esprit humain de
pouvoir nuancer les choses et je suis
estomaqué de voir sur France Info c'est
tous les matins qu'il y a de débat entre
droite et gauche alors mdiapart et Rue
89 ou bien Libération et Le Figaro ou
bien les journalistes tout à fait
estimable mais il est de notre devoir il
devrait être du devoir du Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel d'imposer que
précisément on on on on refuse
de bloquer le débat à deux positions qui
forcément sont réductrices et forcément
caricatural comme s'il n'y avait que
deux légitimités en France et ceci est
le
contraire pas seulement de la démocratie
de délibération mais de la démocratie de
représentation et ça pose évidemment la
question de nos institutions parce que
oui nos institutions elles sont
absolument pas démocratiques en ce
qu'elles ne représentent que une partie
euh finalement assez faible du corps
électoral y compris dans les médias et
donc il y a il y a dans cette question
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
profond et qui touche euh au fond à
l'idée que nous nous formons de de de
l'esprit humain et de la société dans
laquelle nous vivons pardon de cette
intervention
euh euh
masculin ah là c'est chouchou c'est
comme
çaour
é tu as raison tu as
raison tape tape tape dessus peut-être
il marche voilà merci madame cota vous
avez dit plein de choses très très
intéressantes très vraies surtout une
grande acité c'est votre expérience et
vous avez aussi posé une question à la
salle en fait si j'ai bien compris donc
je vais pas vous poser de question je
vais vous donner une réponse mais c'est
la mienne bien sûr en ce qui
concerne cette peur que vous que
vous dites
ressentir pour la démocratie à cause de
ce fourmillement
de
réactions diverses et parfois de qualité
c'est vrai un peu douteuse mais souvent
sincère souvent souvent venant du cœur
des
gens je suis moi un peu plus rassuré
parce que j'essaie de sortir de ce Brou
à en me disant que je suis devant une
grosse ruche que dans cette ruche il y a
des millions d'abeilles que chaque
abeille a son point de vue chaque
abeille fait son petit chemin mais qu'au
bout du compte on va récolter quelque
chose donc j'aurais une vision beaucoup
plus positive de tout ça pour moi ce
n'est pas du tout la réflexion
individuelle qui met la démocratie en
danger je sais très bien que dans un un
certain moment quelqu'un comme Marcel
dasso qui a aussi été un peu journaliste
disait que c'était le café du commerce
ben je veux bien c'est bien le café du
commerce a toujours existé je pense pas
que ça aille vraiment plus loin je pense
que la véritable responsabilité ce sont
certains hommes politiques qui
lapportent parce qu'il se servent de ce
broua là en en tirant des lignes de
force qui ne sont pas des lignes de
force de de réalité mais des lignes de
force qui les intéresse et qui visent
toujours à la division toujours à monter
une communauté contre une autre et ils
vont effectivement utiliser ces systèmes
de blog de tweet pour pouvoir comment
dire amplifier le mouvement là il y a
danger ce n'est pas la machine qui
provoque le danger ce sont les hommes
politiques qui se serent de la machine
euh j'insiste là-dessus parce que c'est
un espace de liberté vous l'avez dit
c'est un espace de liberté
merveilleux ici au Mouvement Démocrate
nous discussons entre nous dans des
groupes ouverts dans des fois dans des
groupes privés mais nous discutons entre
nous c'est souvent je dirais presque
hard les les discussions que nous
pouvons avoir sur des sujets compliqués
mais on arrive toujours au bout du
compte à se mettre d'accord et ça c'est
absolument formidable c'est c'est c'est
beaucoup plus positif que le risque donc
je pense que c'est l'homme politique et
par derrière lui les réseaux qui le
maintiennent et les lobis qui sont
responsables de de cette force là
Jean-Pierre Riou a parlé tout à l'heure
de toujours dans la même veine donc de
démocratie constitutionnelle oui
excusez-moi François de démocratie
constitutionnelle et de temporalité et
d'ordre du jour il y a des ordres du
jour qui se crent naturellement dans ces
médias là parce qu'il y a un sujet qui
est donné donc il y a un ordre du jour
virtuel en aucun cas ça ne peut toucher
la démocratie puisque ces personnes là
n'ont aucun pouvoir de décision voilà un
sondage ferait en fait exactement
exactement la même chose donc pour moi
c'est très très positif j'espère qu'on
va continuer à se battre sur Twitter sur
Facebook par la correction ou par
l'insulte ça n'est pas bien grave parce
que c'est l'âme humaine qui s'exprime
c'est très sain finalement tout ça et
puis euh je n'ai pas peur de l'avenir
dans ce sens-là merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
oui c'est
l'bnis euh euh non féminin
oui bonsoir euh non ça
m'étonnerait bonsoir moi je voudrais
rebondir sur ce que vient dire notre ami
euh nous avons Madame Michelle cota vous
nous avez parlé brillamment évidemment
de ce sujet mais au sens localement
j'allais dire moi je voudrais aller plus
loin je voudrais mettre l'accent sur
l'intérêt du temps numérique dans les
autres enfin au niveau international et
je voudrais surtout vous Rappelz ce
enfin le le rôle de ce temps numérique
pour les révolutions Arab qui a donc là
c'était au niveau des sociétés civiles
donc la confiscation de l'information
par la les sociétés civiles d'ailleurs
TS numérique et démocratie je mettrai un
s à démocratie pour parler notamment de
ces révolutions et je voudrais savoir
quelle a été votre impression quand vous
avez vu justement au niveau en tant que
journaliste au niveau international que
l'information a été confisquée par une
des sociétés civiles et qui sont même
pas basées en France merci beaucoup
masculin
oui bonsoir J'ai le micro donc j'en
profite donc la question est la suivante
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que tout
ce
foisonnement ne peut pas conduire
finalement à une plus grande
transparence et un peu à l'abandon de
secret pour rebondir sur votre anecdote
tout à l'heure finalement pendant un
mois il y a eu une espèce de presque de
délit d'initié d'un certain cercle de
personnes qui par savait que po
entiellnement monsieur shirac
démissionnait alors que le bas peuple
évidemment il était pas du tout au
courant alors que avec maintenant la
possibilité que chacun parce qu'il a
entendu une chose la partage ce type de
finalement de de
secret n'aurait plus lieu
d'être merci beaucoup à toi on voit bien
que là effectivement c'est la version
optimiste des des choses qui se fait
entendre c'est tant mieux parce que je
me suis gardé j'ai posé des
interrogations sur les dangers mais au
fond moi vous me rassurez plutôt en
disant après tout que les gens
parlent c'est parfait mais vous ne
répondez pas vous pensez que c'est des
abeilles
individuelles mais à un moment donné il
faut bien que ces abeilles individuelles
soient conduites quelque part ou se
conduisent quelque part donc la
démocratie elle est quand même
délibérative alors dans votre club de
réflexion moi je suis tout à fait alors
là pour les clubs deé félexion qui se
mettent ensemble 50 personnes qui
délibèent il y a une délibération parce
que c'est très bien les abeilles mais à
un moment donné il faut que la haine
fasse du miel voilà elle décide de donc
à un moment donné il y a
oui dis vas-y la comparaison je ne suis
pas absolument sûr que ce soit la reine
qui fasse le miel mais bon pour le reste
oui elle incite je sais pas je reconnais
qu'en matière de en matière de ruralité
je suis pas formidable
ou et alors au fond moi s'il y a une
délibération et si les gens sont assez
sensés pour dire on pense ce qu'on pense
mais on se rallie au plus grand nombre
ça me gêne pas du tout le problème c'est
je ne suis pas sûr que chacun n'it pas
une vérité individuelle qu'il refuse
absolument de partager c'est ça qui me
fait peur c'est pas la la technique
effectivement de d'chang alors euh
je répondrai à la plus grande
transparence oui vous avez raison vous
avez raison ça aussi c'est le meilleur
aspect qu'on peut trouver à cette
embrasement permanent d'Internet et à
cet intérêt par oui si on arrive à ça
c'est parfait mais si on arrive à
euh jeter un trouble définitive sur la
transparence des hommes politiqu c'est
c'est eux qu'on met en cause donc on
voit aussi comment ça peut passer du
meilleur côté c'est-à-dire chacun est
quand même tenu à la transparence à
partir du moment où il a une fonction o
il exerce une fonction il exerce un rôle
oui à cette nuance près que ça peut
devenir une mise en cause systématique
cette transparence elle-même peut être m
en cause par n'importe quelle
affirmation donc la transparence peut se
retourner vers au contraire un défaut
majeur de transparence voilà ça fait
partie aussi des craintes et enfin sur
le temps numérique et la révolution
arabe alors je je ne sais pas exactement
je vais vous dire ce que j'en ai pensé
hein mais je suis pas sûr de répondre à
votre question
euh moi je suis très très dubitative sur
la manière dont C dont l'annonce de ces
révolutions euh par ailleurs tout à fait
incité par euh tel
euh telimolation en direct par la
télévision du Qatar euh de un jeune
Tunisien euh moi j'ai trouvé que
justement et j'en suis conforté par
l'évolution actuelle je ne suis pas sûr
que la couverture immédiate de ces
révolutions arabes est été formidable
voilà je je je peut-être je vous je vous
déçois ENF en attendant c'est ce que je
pense et je pense qu'en
attendant lorsque le problème de l'Islam
n'a jamais été posé dans ces premières
révolutions moi je suis choqué parce que
moi je me l'a supposé en premier voilà
et
bon je donc là je peux pas vous répondre
je ne trouve pas que la façon dont la
révolution a été aidée tienne du du de
la perfection non je pense que chacun
chacun des protagonistes secrets il est
allé de sa petite musique sans le
montrer excusez-moi
c'estop l'idée ma question pas céit de
attends on va vous donner micro parce
qu'autrement ça n'est pas
enregistré je voulais simplement mettre
l'accent sur l'importance de justement
du temps numérique euh des blogs de la
part la participation de la société
civile euh pour les le déclenchement de
ces révolutions on sait tous que il y a
eu énormément d'informations qui ont
circulé avant avant ces révolutions
entre amis au départ ensuite enfin vous
je vais pas vous refaire l'histoire donc
je veux dire parce que c'est pour
revenir sur
épu passé as ce qui s passé avant et
vous avez raison de ce point de
vue une
espérance un fouillli révolutionnaire
est sûrement positif et important et
d'ailleurs tous les hommes politiques en
tiennent compte je suis d'accord avec ça
c'est après la
façon oui ça ne marche pas partout
exemple la Syrie dit Jean-Pierre rou
comme je vois le temps qui non seulement
passe mais a
passé euh si non pas pour faire avancer
davantage simplement pour que la
réflexion
essaie de
s'organiser encore un peu
mieux je crois que d'abord on aurait dû
expliquer Michel et moi et Jean-Pierre
ce que temps numérique voulait dire
démocratie est tant numérique parce que
je crois qu'il y avait deux
significations que nous avons ardemment
mélangé dans le le jeu des choses euh
comme nous avons mélangé encore d'autres
notions temps numérique il y avait deux
acceptions et on s'en est pas aperçu en
parlant mais ça m'a frappé au cours du
débat temps numérique ça veut dire que
nous sommes dans un temps numérique le
temps l'époque dans laquelle nous sommes
nous sommes en époque numérique
c'est-à-dire que le le le le entre
Internet et les télévisions
numériques un certain nombre de
phénomènes sont
intervenus nous sommes en époque
numérique et de sur croix le chronomètre
le temps du chronomètre le la la
vitesse d'expression de l'information ne
cesse de s'accroître et le mot temps
était ambigu parce que il avait la
double signification donc il importe de
l'éclaircir une seconde
deè éclaircissement je crois qu'on
confond deux choses ou plus exactement
on ne se focalise pas sur deux choses il
y a dans l'époque numérique dans
laquelle nous sommes deux
phénomènes qui se s'exacerbent l'un
l'autre le premier de ces phénomènes
c'est que l'émission d'information est
devenue
universelle hier l'émission
d'information était entre des mains
extrêmement
peu nombreus on citait les
agences ça a encore une importance les
agences he ne croyez pas que ça ne
compte pour rien je puis vous assurer
que quand vous êtes dans un courant
politique qui n'a pas de médias officiel
les agences ça vous aide beaucoup hein
parce que ça répercute dans la totalité
des mais il y avait très peu d'émetteur
d'information les hommes politiques
l'était les journalistes l'étaient
c'était une petite tribu très peu
nombreuse euh inégalement sympathique
mais quelquefois sympathique et qui au
fond connaissait les codes les unes des
autres aujourd'hui tout le monde est
devenu émetteur d'information et c'est
une libération en effet ça peut être une
formidable chance quelquefois évidemment
la fiabilité de l'émetteur est en
cause moins qu'on ne croire mais enfin
ça
existe je sais pas si c'est comme avant
je sais pas qui a dit comme avant mais
ça ça existe il y
a mais du coup et c'est l'affaire des
révolutions arabes
des
sujets pas des citoyens des gens qui
étaient soumis à un pouvoir et qui
n'avait pas la parole peuvent la prendre
pas toujours on le voit en Syrie pas
toujours on le voit en Chine excusez-moi
de le dire au passage il y a quand même
1300000 personnes qui sont contrôlé de
ce point de vue-là 1illard 300000
personnes 300 millions de personnes qui
sont contrôler puis en plus c'est moi
qui fait cette faute alors là c'est
c'est impardonnable parce que je me bat
toujours pour le calcul mental dans ces
enceintes et j'explique que 1 milliard
c'est 1000 millions ce que beaucoup de
gens ignorent et
donc et donc
cette
multiplication de la liberté d'émettre
de l'information est un phénomène très
important mais dans le même temps il y a
un deuxième phénomène qui exacerbe
celui-là c'est
que l'information de est prise dans une
telle accélération perpétuelle qu'on ne
peut plus fixer son attention
l'obsolescence est instantané quelque
chose monterl
écrivait de tout ce qu'il y a dans les
journaux au bout de 6 mois il reste ce
qui reste d'une danse de mouche dans un
rayon de
soleil mitteran disait il y a rien de
plus vieux que le journal de la
veille et maintenant il y a rien de plus
vie que ce que vous avez vu 5 minutes
avant alors c'est quelque chose de de
très
étonnant Michel a fait allusion au même
phénomène qui moi me frappe depuis
longtemps autrefois du temps de mon
enfance dans les rues des
villages les gens attendaient que le
députés reviennent pour leur expliquer
ce qui se passait à
Paris quelques décennies après il y a
encore 4 ou 5 ans il descendait du train
le député c'était le chauffeur taxi qui
lui expliquait sur France Info ce qui se
passait mais maintenant c'est le rapport
du
FMI je quitte la maison l'autre soir
j'avais une réunion du même genre dans
ma circonscription à poau euh tu y étais
je quitte la maison il y avait euh sur
un site improbable le l' alité d'un
rapport de d'une agence de notation qui
analysait une partie de la situation de
la France ou de l'Allemagne je sais plus
je vais à la Réunion c'était à maer il y
a quatre personnes qui ont parlé de ce
truc dans la
réunion un rapport hyper pointintu d'une
agence de notation qui disait que le la
le le l'agrégat de la création
monétaire le M3 était
et c'est
formidable
c'est extraordinaire parce que il n'y a
plus aucun
monopole non plus d'émission seulement
mais de d'analyse de l'information on
a on a tous vécu ici en un temps
quelquesuns en tout cas les plus gé en
un temps où le
BQ apportait des secrets et maintenant
les secrets sont à la disposition de
tout le monde quel que soit le degré de
technicité du secret donc c'est
absolument fascinant mais ça cette
médaille a un revers extrêmement
inquiétant c'est que
l'attention ne peut plus se
fixer et celui qui avait compris ça
admirablement c'est Nicolas Sarkozy il y
a un chapitre de mon livre qui s'appelle
abus de pouvoir sur le jeu que Nicolas
Sarkozy avait compris si tu accélère
suffisamment le nombre des événements
que tu crées plus personne ne peut te
mettre dans le viseur et te choper au
passage parce que tu as déjà créé euh
quatre événements depuis le moment où tu
as fait un discours impossible sur
l'homme africain ou un discours
impossible sur la laïcité au Latran ou
je sais plus quoi ça tu vas tellement
vite il avait compris ce qui est un
mérite
important théoriser et
appliquer ce qui fait qu'il a échappé au
viseur pendant longtemps jusqu'au jour
où et donc
oui mais mais c'est très important et
c'est très
intéressant parce que par exemple avec
François Hollande on voit que
disons c'est inégalement maîtrisé cette
affaire et ça veut dire une chose qui en
tout cas pour moi avant d'avoir les
dernières questions de vous et la
réponse de Michel et peut-être de
Jean-Pierre c'est pour moi la leçon de
toutes ces choses au
fond c'est tout à fait
nouveau et ça
exigeai les vertus les plus anciennes
qu'un homme poltique en démocratie
devrait avoir la capacité de mettre de
l'ordre dans la pensée la capacité de
tracer des
lignes la capacité de dire à ceux qu'il
représentent où ils en sont et où ils
vont et de le répéter assez souvent je
rappelle que c'est la pédagogie ça
enseigner c'est répéter souvent de le
répéter assez souvent pour que nul ne
l'oublie et ce qui me frappe dans la
période que nous sommes en train de
vivre c'est au contraire l'incapacité où
l'on est à fixer les esprits ce qui est
à mon sens une faiblesse du moment que
nous sommes en train de traverser à vous
pour les dernières
questions on en était
à à masculin alors féminin
oui de ce côté voilà tu vas te faire
engueuler
féminin non mais vous allez avoir la
parole madame vous vouliez la parole non
c'est pas vous qui vouliez j'ai vu une
main féminine
là-dedans pas beaucoup plus tard ce sont
les trois dernières
questions et la presse écrite dans tout
ça Michel cota que pensez-vous de
l'avenir des magazines où il y a des
réflexions où les journalistes prennent
un peu de recul à la vitesse où ça va
j'ai l'impression que c'est ça va pas
être très facile dans les années qui
viennent masculin alors le monsieur
qui
merci bonsoir David Bouchard donc Michel
cota vous nous avez démontré que vous
étiez une femme de de télévision que
vous avez compté beaucoup pour la pour
la télévision et que en en fait vous
avez expliqué au début que internet en
fait c'était le le début le tâonnement
qu'on savait pas encore exactement ce
que internet allait donner dans dans
dans les années qui viennent en fait on
est au tout début d'internet on est au
tout début des réseaux sociaux et vous
nous avez dit excusez-moi je tremble un
petit peu nous avez vous nous avez dit
que en fait ce qui avait précédé les
réseaux sociaux c'était la
téléréalité c'était ce qu' avait permis
enfin ce qui avait
précédé ce qu'on vit actuellement
c'està-dire le virtuel et et Monsieur
François Baayou vous nous avez dit au
début de de de l' de votre intervention
d'ailleurs ça m'a un petit peu un petit
peu surpris que vous commenciez par
parler de de la saga
UMP on a soupé pendant 5 semaines et et
on on va peut-être continuer en souper
et PS pareil donc en fait je voudrais
vous poser une question par rapport à
finalement quelle est la place du du
centre aujourd'hui dans les médias
quelle est la place du Mouvement
Démocrate Mouvement Démocrate c'est
c'est un c'est le plus c'est pluraliste
non c'est pas j'entends quelque chose
derrière je pense pas que ça soit horors
sujet euh et onarrête pas on narrête pas
en fait d'entendre PS UMP sans arrêt et
en fait alors la petite réflexion que je
voulais faire à la salle c'est que ce
weekend il s'est passé quelque chose au
modem il y a eu un conseil national on
en a absolument pas entendu
parler non non mais c'est pas par
rapport à donc en fait je voulais en
fait connaître un petit peu quelle est
la place du centre quelle doit être la
place du centre dans les médias
voilà merci
beaucoup dernière question
féminine dommage
oui c'est à
vous merci moi je voudrais revenir sur
l'idée de hiérarchisation des
informations euh parce que je pense en
effet que dans les médias médias
audiovisuels notamment euh la
hiérarchisation est tout de même sujette
à on va dire à interrogation par le pour
pour la plupart des gens et je me
demandais si justement l'explosion euh
des blogs euh ne proviendrait-elle pas
aussi euh de ce fait que les gens se
sentent de plus en plus exclus euh de
cette caricature d'information de cette
simplification en permanence qui fait
qu'on a même plus envie d'écouter la
télévision même alors parfois c'est vrai
il y a des exceptions des journalistes
un peu plus doués que d'autres qui
posent des questions parfois plus
intelligentes que d'autres avec plus de
nuance moi c'est la nuance qui
m'intéresse et c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression qu'il refuse presque la
nuance parce qu'elle est sujette à à
réflexion et non pas à catégorisation et
la catégorisation est souvent plus
facile à on va dire à faire rentrer dans
les têtes sauf que c'est pas je pense le
plus intéressant pour la plupart des
gens et également pour notre avenir
voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire merci
beaucoup réponse de Michel il y en a une
auquelle c'est toi qui doit répondre
mais
alors je suis très sensible à la
question sur l'avenir de la presse
écrite d'abord parce que je viens de la
presse écrite que j'aime la presse
écrite et que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
réticence à l'égard des télévisions de
la télévision en général du du média
télévision enfin bon c'est un autre
sujet alors vous dirait que je suis
pessimiste ce soir mais vous m'avez
plutôt vous m'avez
plutôt encouragé bon moi ma crainte ce
soit que la presse écrite est quand même
la base pour le moment la presse écrite
et la télévision sont classique sont la
base de toutes les information c'est par
ça que passent les grands reportages
c'est par ça qu'on est
euh on est instruit sur ce qui se passe
dans tel ou tel et moi j'ai peur que la
l'obsolence de la presse écrite qui on
voit très bien quand même que le déclin
de la presse écrite a vraiment commencé
gravement n'aboutissse finalement àce
qu'on n pas ce corps d'information
important alors après il s'agit de
hiérarchiser bien ou mais si on l'a plus
du tout je suis très inquiète et
notamment si l'ensemble des des de la
presse écrite euh disparaissait c'est
progressivement je veux pas dire d'un
coup moi je pense que là vraiment ce
serait quelque chose de grave parce
qu'alors on aurait plus de base sur
laquelle disserté on peut être pour on
peut être contre mais bon voilà donc
j'ai je suis très sensible à la venir la
presse écrite et je me fais beaucoup de
soucis parce que moi-même pour lire la
presse écrite je suis passé pour des
tablettes je suis passé sur des
tablettes parce que mon cusqu est jamais
ouvert que je trouve jamais le journal
que quand j'ai un abonnement il est pas
distribué et cetera donc il y a un vrai
vrai gros problème de la presse écrite
qui m' qui m'inquiète beaucoup enfin pas
dans l'immédiat pas dans l'immédiat mais
qui m'inquiète à terme alors le
le la question sur la hiérarchisation
d'information vous avez raison c'est
vrai que quand je dis que mais j'ai des
réserves vis-à-vis du médiia télévision
c'est ça que je veux dire c'est vrai que
je trouve que la nuance est très
difficile à à faire passer il faut
affirmer des choses des bonnes grosses
choses comme ça euh et puis le type à
côté vous dit des bonnes grosses choses
en sens inverse mais si vous dites oui
mais c'est pas exactement comme ça les
gens décrochent bon c'est c'est vraiment
le le problème numéro 1 de la télévision
c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il y a une
vraie que je tiens à la complémentarité
entre la télévision et les médias et la
presse écrite parce qu'au moins la
presse écrite donc on se pose on regarde
on a le temps de relire le papier et on
a le temps de faire des nuance
mais je me rappelle ce que disait quand
quand L'Express s'est mis à faire des
papiers très courts à un moment donné il
très court et évidemment on nous a dit
ah ben ça une idée pas deux une idée et
du coup après ou alors on arrivait à
renverser l'idée à la fin vous voyez à
dire peut-être que ça pourrait être
autrement mais du coup ça devient
incpréhensible donc c'est vrai que on
s'est remis à faire des papiers un peu
plus longs pour avoir au moins deux
idées dans le même papier c'est pas dit
que les gensent donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec votre votre interrogation
quand à la place quand à la place du
centre au fond pas politique mais sur
les médias ça relève un peu de ça ça
relève un peu de ça c'est
qu'effectivement quand vous dites cette
idée est très bonne mais faudrait
peut-être y ajouter tel correctif et
tout ça les gens laissai tomber la
deuxième or je vois bien que le centre
n'existe que s'il met en cause justement
et certaines certaines affirmations de
la droite et certaines affirmations de
la gauche sinon il existerait pas et je
trouve qu'évidemment le M non mais il
n'existerait pas bon d'accord enfin bon
c'est mon idée je la
et et donc oui je pense aussi que cette
simplification des médias joue contre le
centre
oui absolument
euh non c'est pas vrai je me fais jamais
non non franchement franchement je
trouve que B
oui mais bon je résiste c'est pas non je
vais au fond on a abordé cette affaire
là on a
parlé de passion c'est sont des médias
passionnels on a parlé
d'accélération ce sont des médias dans
lesquels on n plus le temps de traiter
on ne prend plus le temps mon avis c'est
ça va changer hein mais aujourd'hui
c'est comme ça on prend plus le temps de
traiter les
choses et ce sont des médias d'absolu
simplification
il n'y a plus que deux opinions un pour
un contre un droite contre gauche et
simplement tout ça ça ne va pas
permettre à la société d'avancer il va y
avoir une très grande insatisfaction à
l'égard de ces choses je suis persuadé
que ce que vous avez dit si on était en
direct devant 10 millions de personnes
il y aurait vous avez dit moi c'est la
nuance qui m'intéresse je veux plus
qu'on m'enferme dans des positions aussi
étroites et en fait stupide fausse par
définition n'est-ce pas le l'histoire de
l'intelligence de l'Occident en tout cas
sur les six derniers siècles c'est
précisément qu'on voulait avoir de la
nuance on voulait plus obéir à une
pensée préformée et on voulait au
contraire que des pensées se forment et
les gens qui ont fait les grandes
révolutions Pascal par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit Pascal il a dit
attention vous ne pouvez pas accepter
qu'il y ait une seule vérité révélée
parce que selon l'ordre dans lequel vous
êtes la vérité n'est pas la même la
vérité scientifique n'est pas du même
ordre que la vérité religieuse n'est pas
du même ordre que la vérité
politique votre liberté votre
émancipation c'est que personne ne peut
vous obliger à être dans un seul sous
une seule autorité é s'appelle la
distinction des ordres c'est la chose la
plus géniale qui a jamais été écrite
c'est la naissence de la démocratie
contemporaine et de la laïcité et toutes
ces choses de la part d'un cerveau qui
était fait un peu plus structuré que un
certain nombre de ceux que nous avons
évoqué là et donc je crois que ça va
finir mais c'est tout ça qui pousse à ce
Ce à cette antagonisation et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue-là les signes
sont mauvais j'étéis stupéfait je vais
vous dire ces dernières heures
j'étais stupéfait par l'affaire de par
Dieu d'abord par l'abondance des
commentaires et par le fait
que toute la gauche était
contre et toute la droite était pour et
c'est la première fois dans ma vie que
je vois la
droite prendre une position aussi
ouvertement
antipatriotique
c'est moi je suis du bord du
pogon je suis du bord du
fric jamais ça s'est produit jusqu'à ce
jour et alors c'était très intéressant
vous avez évoqué le Conseil national je
bas ma coupe parce que c'est moi qui ai
pas voulu faire pour une fois de
conférence de presse parce que je
trouvais qu'on avait des sujets à
discuter qui étaient précisément des
sujets profonds alors je vais faire un
compte-rendu que je vais mettre sur
internet je vais en parler j'en ai parlé
à un journaliste cet après-midi un
agencier justement euh donc il y aura
des petits échos mais je ça mérite en
effet qu'on en parle mais j'ai pas voulu
entrer dans ce jeu-là mais euh Rochefort
a expliqué au Conseil national quelque
chose d'extrêmement juste euh parce
qu'on avait tout le débat sur udi euh et
il a expliqué quelque chose
d'extrêmement juste il dit c'est la
première fois depuis 50 ans qu'un
électorat particulier original est né au
centre il dit l'électorat modem dans les
sondages ne ressemble pas aux autres et
bien j'avais à l'instant sous les yeux
le sondage de pardu qui vient d'être
fait par Louis Haris qui était sur mon
écran juste avant que je ne descende et
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
en
effet de par Dieu condamné par 80 % de
la gauche et 15 %
comprennent de par Dieu approuvé c'est
ça qui me rend triste par 80 % de la
droite et et 11 % sont contre lui et le
seul électorat singulier c'est le nôtre
qui est à
48 comprenant plutôt et 47 ne comprenant
pas c'est la première
fois très intéressant parce que l'UDI
est
absolument à l'unité près sur les
positions de
l'UMP et c'était et Rochefort citait ça
sur trois ou quatre grands sujet
économique et social il n'y a pas de
différence entre les deux électorats et
je le vérifiais ce soir encore et cette
singularité là de ceux qui précisément
veulent de la nuance de la compréhension
pas être d'un côté et pas être de
l'autre pas être dans la caricature
exigeant que la démocratie sorte autre
chose que de l'agressivité d'un bord
contre l'autre c'est vrai que en
l'instant précis on a l'impression que
tout se radicalise sur le mariage gay
sur l'thanasie sur tout ça et d'être
dans le camp de ceux qui
disent
le la société et les êtres humains ont à
élaborer une vérité qui soit plus
compréhensive plus plus ouverte plus
empathique que ce qu'on a tous les jours
et ben c'est une grande chance et c'est
la chance que vous avez merci à Michel
cotta d'être venu ce
soir
sur
S oui oh
pardon nous avons rendez-vous je ne dis
je ne vous dirai pas avec qui mais notez
bien les deux prochaines séances le 15
janvier et le 30
janvier il en aura
d'autres